Now let's write a function to solve the missionary and cannibals problem.
It takes a start state.
Here's the normal problem: 3 missionary, 3 cannibals, and 1 boat on the start side.
Nothing on the other side, and it takes a goal state.
The goal state is not specified. It's just the opposite of that--3, 3, 1 on the other side.
Nothing on the original side.
The state is this 6-tuple, and we're trying to find a path from the initial state to the goal state.
In fact, we're trying to find the path with the least number of steps.
I'm not going to ask you to do this as a quiz.
If you're enthusiastic, you can stop the video now
and go ahead and solve it on your own, but now I'm going to go ahead and show it to you.
Here's a solution that looks pretty much like the pouring water problem.
We check to see if the goal is None, then we fix up a nice goal.
We check to see if we've accidentally already reached the goal at the start.
Then we just search for the shortest path.